In this video I create a website called Cobot to converse with the DanKoe
letters using custom GPT.ai and host it within a conversational bot. Let's
create a chat bot called co-chat that allows you to interact with a website.
Here we'll read the DanKoe letters and we have all these letters here and we'll be
able to go down to the bot and type in a question and get an answer.
custom GPT.ai creates your own chat GPT with all your business content. Got a
landing page, pricing, we have three custom projects for $50 a month. So what
I think I'll do is let's click on this button, let's just log in and see how we
can use this product. Now I've come through to a dashboard and we've got my
project and create a project which looks like it's in three different
locations. There's some help documentation. If I click on create a
project I am taken straight to a pricing page. I wonder if I type in free. It's
not showing up on the page. I've come to the home page and I typed in a question
into the chat bot. Is there a free trial? Saying that they don't have a free trial
at the moment. Maybe they will in the future but demand is high and they've
got costs. That's fair enough. They've got a demo here. I may buy this for one
month. There's a particular idea that I want to test out this bot. DanKoe is this
influencer that I've been following just as I learn how to develop my own brand
and what I've liked about his information is that he educates people on how to do
something they're passionate about and I'm actually passionate about technology
and just teaching people about it. He has this area here called Letters. All these
blog posts that have written over a couple of years I think might be a really
good set of information to do a Q&A bot against. Let's go back to custom GPT and
it has this idea of an XML sitemap. This is a data document that websites have
usually called something like sitemap.xml. Let's have a look at what they look
like. Google images here typed in sitemap.xml and this is usually the sort of
format that they come in but what they do in essence is create a graph of the
web pages that the site owner would like you to go to. So it's not every page on
the site but it's the one you want to go to. Hopefully when we go and have a look
at DanKoe's website there will be a sitemap that we can use to put back into
this section right here. I've headed over to the website thedanKoe.com and put
in sitemap.xml and you end up with this sitemap and it looks like the way he's
got it laid out is that he's got various categories and the one I'm actually
interested in is called letters.sitemap. I'll just click on that and what we
should see is a list of letters that he has written. I guess they're just
articles. If we were to click on one of them it should take us to that article.
We've got an article, we've got a video, we've got a whole lot of text and it's
the text that's in each of these articles that I would like to do a question
and answer but against. I've just grabbed the URL, let's paste it in here,
thedanKoe.com letters.xml, it says that it's okay. I guess this is where we
created a project. I have DanKoe items found, items indexed, I've got no
information here. I clicked on this button and I ended up getting this list of
documents. Some of them are queued. I guess that's reading those articles off the
web. We're now up to 69 items indexed. We've got 85 founds and we've got some
words indexed. What happens if we go in one more time? Missing or queued are now
loaded. I'll do now is test this bot out. Click on this ask me anything button.
We have new conversation. The question I've asked is what is DanKoe known for
and why would I subscribe to his bot? We'll just click this button and it's
starting to come up thinking at the moment. DanKoe is known as a writer and
brand advisor for creators, influencers and social media figures that are in the
seven to eight figure range. He has a deep interest in exploring human potential,
lifestyle design and one person business. You know what I might do? I might ask
this same question in chat GPT and compare what that comes up with. We'll head
over to chat GPT. I'm running the GPT for model and I've got basically the same
question coming through right here. This is a very typical of chat GPT to come up
with this as my last update September 2001. I'm really happy with this custom
GPT bot already. I know that Dan has increased in popularity really quickly
over a few years. It's just given me generic terms of just do it yourself,
which is a pain in the bum. So if we go back to the bot, we've got additional
information. I might just read this subscribing to his blog, the code letter.
It's good for a couple of reasons gain insights about life and business.
He offers a free planner. He offers a course to our writer.
This is one of the things I'm interested in learning is just how to become a better writer.
The way I like to interact with chat GPT, I really do want to become a better writer
while we're using chat GPT as a tool to enhance myself. I want to bring these two concepts together
and he shares his experience on in digital economics to help you productize yourself
brain content marketing. The other thing that I really enjoy when I listen to his
YouTube videos, this idea of building a business around what you love doing,
five different sources, a message from a recovering atheist, how to find God.
Learn this skill if you want to thrive in the next 10 years.
As I look through them all, they're all coming out of the letters on his website.
This is great. It's drawing inspiration directly off his blog.
First follow up question is, as a new business owner, creating content on YouTube,
what are the first five steps that I should focus on? Keep it as a simple list and I'm using my
understanding of prompt engineering that I use all the time with chat GPT to formulate these
questions. Hudson GPT has come up with five answers. Understand high performing content,
build an email list, develop your ideas. This is about writing and creating a product or service
and consider paid growth. One of the reasons I started following Dan is that I want to learn
how to write and to do email marketing. I don't currently have an email list, but by the time
I publish this video, I will and I'll make sure there's a link in the description. I currently
don't have anything to sell, but custom GPT.ai have an affiliate program. I'll put an affiliate
link in the description and that would help the channel if you decide that this is a product
you want to explore further. The last point here, consider paid growth. These are all pretty good
answers, but the reason I've created a bot against this particular set of information is that I want
to learn the art of creating YouTube titles, headlines, those sorts of messages that I've
a convert, they create curiosity, people go, wow, I want to know about that topic. And I think that
should be what my next prompt should be about. So I've created a question here. I want to know how
to write titles for YouTube, Twitter and blog posts that create engagement, curiosity and clicks.
Where do I start? Understand your audience using power words. It's given an example of a few power
words, have a clear and short title, especially for Twitter and YouTube, use numbers, so five ways
other platforms create a sense of urgency. And one of the things I could follow up with a question
is what does that mean? What are examples of creating a sense of urgency and testing different
titles? Now, let's see how I have done this in the past and how this is going to add a lot of value
to what I do in the future. Head over to ChatGPT where I have a lot of bots that I've created in
the past. A few that are important start with the letter YT. It's for YouTube. We have the YouTube
description, YouTube title, creation tips one, creation tips two. And these are variations of
bots that I've created just for doing YouTube titles. If we were to click on one of them,
you can see that I often just give it a simple keyword and a title that just comes out of my
head. What did I think this video happened to be about in layman's terms? I end up getting a bunch
of relatively good YouTube titles. You sometimes need to edit them a little bit,
but it does a lot of the heavy lifting for me. And the way I initially created this bot about six
months ago, you are a specialist in YouTube title creation. I preloaded it with a bunch of information
that I learned from people like MrBeast and watching different YouTube influencers who were
top of their game, how they wrote headlines. This has been pretty good for me so far, but it's a
monkey see monkey do approach to using ChatGPT. These days, I have more skills in the area of
automating ChatGPT through programming and through learning through people like DanKoe.
I can also start to understand how what it means to be a good writer, the psychology of headlines.
I'd like to feed knowledge into my title and description generation bots. And this is what
led me to trailing custom GPT.ai. I think it might be useful to do something with this chat bot.
Maybe we can put it on our website or HTML page. One of the things I've noticed is if I come back
to my projects, I wasn't sure how to get back into the chat. I know there's a question here,
but I don't see previous chats. I did find out if that you click on the ask me anything.
You can get to previous chats over here on the left. Previous chat bot, we've got a background,
we've got a logo, maybe that can be DanKoe. If we click over on settings, we have the ability to go
to, let's click on this user experience, conversation settings, custom persona. Oh, this
is cool. This probably like a system prompt in chat GPT. But I think this is the one I want to
work with. We have a color, have a background, other information. We will upload a new image.
I might create one with mid journey. So the sharing has we've got embeds. This is the sort of stuff
we'd want on a HTML page. I'll just turn that off for now because I'm not sure whether I need to do
that after updating this information. Just brought me journey up Terry Potter in Pixar,
some Donald Duck, and let's head over to this window because it's DanKoe chat bot,
one as well gives the likeness of him copy image address should be good enough. I'm just going
to do something really simple, paste image of his profile in the style of Steve Irwin,
Bill Ochre, Australian legend with a crocodile that look interesting. They're okay. This one's
pretty good. This one, I think if I go back and look at the original image, he's looking off to
the right. I think that might be a good one to work with. We'll do an upscale on number four.
You could also do number two before we'll do. I've uploaded his image. I've set the color to black.
I'm not going to worry about the background image. What I'll do now is I'll take a little bit of
time out just to create a HTML page that might be able to host this particular embedding.
Everything appears to be working now on the chat bot. The only challenge I've got now is
the color scheme here. Let's go over to mid-journey and I've gone and created a few images here.
I'm just looking for a color that might fit in. I've just gone dark blue streaks with light
on a background. I better do the aspect ratio 16.9 and we will just try one of them out.
Maybe this one will see what it does. Let's head into the chat bot and we've got this change
image that we can click on here. I've downloaded a couple. I reckon we'll work with that one.
Do we have a save? We have a save button. Let's head back to the website and we can just hit
really fresh and there we go.